danke ich jetzt mal was mit musik rallye
setzen und was ist heidis untröstlich
antrieb um immer wieder mit menschen
aufzubrechen
wie meinen längst angekommen zu sein
davon handelt dieser film
halt die vorher ist gastgeberin dieser
erfahrenen reisegesellschaft in
residence reisecar dutzmann sich 75
jährigen zwillinge aus horgen sind wie
viele andere stammgäste
es geht nach frankreich ans meer der bus
gehört der 65-jährige drösel denn seit
30 jahren fährt sie lastwagen bagger und
reisebus unfallfrei war ihr im bus könne
man die zumutungen des alters ein
bisschen vergessen heißt es
hd ist auch schon 70 und kennt die
bedürfnisse ihrer altersgenossinnen
diese kommen vor allem wegen den
rundum-service 101 und nicht mehr
zwischen gut organisiert und mit der
fantasie
eine woche durch frankreich heidi löst
den bus alle probleme darauf können sich
die golden age es auf ihren schon seit
wochen reservierten sitzen absolut
verlassen
heidi fackelt nicht lange wenn es nicht
weitergeht
natürlich müsse er habe ich mehrere
zutaten direkt will nachher im schlaf
machen viel geforscht
[Musik]
nach
richter
[Musik]
erste station clermont ferrand ab heute
werden die rentnerinnen jeden abend in
einem anderen hotel absteigen
das geht nur weil die alles tut damit es
mit zimmer nach dessen klappt gerne
bezahlen die gäste dafür etwas mehr als
bei anderen reiseunternehmen der bus ist
bei baby sagt hösli und nennt in lisa li
sie pflegte ihn bis heute ihre gäste
diese brauchen nicht mehr party sondern
unterstützung wenn der stützstrumpf
zwickt oder der dann streikt genanntes
mecit für durch seine gäste kommen auch
mit der matur ihnen unter annahme ist
für die teams nämlich findet heidi die
ehemalige hebamme nehme zu genau mit dem
putzen
hans lang über sechs jahre später
geschafft
hk verteilt wurde viele nachtschichten
zum beispiel und das ist es für mich
eine user legt sie das macht mir sehr
viel spaß bin ich eigentlich wählen
generationenwechsel im gewehrlauf oder
junge mütter im juni und sie und jetzt
ein bisschen lauter
nicht als bastard noch schnell ein
genuss reisende nennen sie sich es sind
mehrheitlich frauen weil die männer
gestorben oder zumindest verschwunden
sind
was machst du musst das sei sowohl den
start
wo ist das
die kurze bauzeit
inzwischen
sofort ausgezeichnet
das noch um sbb-linie nicht sehr sehr
viel im verhältnis 1488 gelebte jahre
sind auf dieser reise versammelt jeder
hat seine lebens- und krankengeschichte
heidi kennt sie alle
die 75 jährigen gp2 mehrmals pro jahr
mit einem rückgang auf tour
sie haben ihr leben lang fast alles
geteilt
die beiden unterscheidet nur das
rosmarie alle brille trägt und schon
einen herzinfarkt hatte
auch das damals beide druck ist innen in
der elterlichen apotheke geworden sind
war irgendwie logisch
nur einmal ist die fremdgegangen
wir hatten in rust niveau wie der gegner
die eine frau braucht und wo er aber ich
das
wie hier in porto erleben sie
stadtbesichtigungen gerne ohne die
lästigen kopfsteinpflaster der
innenstadt
400 km welt sind so täglich störungsfrei
vorbei
ein bisschen nippen an den erinnerungen
hast inbegriffen und die lebenserfahrung
zeigt dass es bisweilen besser ist sich
auch mal auszuklinken das geld hat und
die kasse schutz genießen oder nach der
pensionierung von alkohol will sie
nichts mehr wissen
zum glück habe jemand geholfen dabei
interviews und jungen hübschen arzt sich
und dankte hektisch und dann daheim ist
das über ein jahr lang heimlich damit
kann ich das und dass ich im eigenen
sticks und angenehmen druckpunkt
dann haben wir super gehört der besseren
[Musik]
trotz klarem kopf passiert des rötlichen
parits kurz vor dem ziel dann doch dass
sie eine straße falsch einschätzt
rechte bemüht
jetzt muss sie zeigen was sie drauf hat
mit ihrem lisa li
[Musik]
das restliche offeriert jetzt sucht aus
aber häufig sehr stark was wie oder sehr
stück raus und werden sich wunderbar
grübelt sie vor allem will ich deshalb
auch ein händler
und jetzt drei oder vier manneskraft
braucht während heute noch beibringen
suchen hilft ist froh dass sie sich auf
die reiseroute konzentrieren kann
für sichere sieht er sie wirklich reden
ist auch sicher zwei gps bus habe dann
noch tropfens studiert und ich hätte
einfach hose aus ganz sicherer grünen
wichtig wenn ich mich absichere fotos
sieht er nur noch von einer seite alles
ist immer gut gegangen es muss wohl eine
art größeren schon vergeben wer alles
lenkt ich werde häufig das stimmt es
gibt nichts zu holen dich ich bin heute
weiß ich also abergläubisch oder ihren
der ölpreis aber ich bete jeden tag
bevor die großen haus grund habe ich
respekt und das darf ich sagen da kann
ich nicht haben und dass mit dem ding
fortfahren
wir sind in biarritz auf dieser reise
merkt man immer wieder die bereifte
abenteurerin hat gewisse ansprüche
könnte sie den himmelblauen und die
wellen größer machen heidi würde es
nicht unversucht lassen in ihrem eigenen
leben hat sie schon einiges bewältigen
müssen
ich habe brustkrebs sag ich jetzt kommt
und mit dem initiator von der diagnose
bis zur operation habe mich entschieden
ganz auf das ist für mich irgendwie hat
das stimmt und die zweite für mich und
das gloria jetzt dass dieser krieg in
sprache kaufte wird dass die ihnen hilft
beim verdrängen wenn sie nämlich im bus
den kaffee serviert ist auch ein offenes
ohr inbegriffen und an der hochschule
zur kontakt- und das ist ja das ist das
klare ja das haben sie hier
hans-joachim spieltagen haben wir immer
fit zu machen
klaus deshalb auch einige sind reich
anderer können sich nicht jedes jahr
eine reise leisten
allen ist gemein wenn sie zu hause fotos
anschauen wollten sie sich nicht als
erstes ans meer erinnern sondern an
dieses schöne gefühl des aufgehoben sein
ein tag mit schlechter frisur ist ein
verlorener tag das gilt auch für die
herbstzeitlosen hat völlig ja dafür eine
zu kehren
von april bis oktober sind rösler und
halt die fast ununterbrochen auf tour
mit ihrem bus sie leben und arbeiten
seit zehn jahren zusammen
bei der ersten begegnung sei es
allerdings noch gar nicht nach etwas
langfristiger aus
servicekraft und der freundlichkeit und
wieder mitfahren da ziehen ihre
kaufkraft teilte der präfekt areal von
genie
[Musik]
b
mit
alles j
natürlich gewann sollte wird wenn dir
ein schöner mann begegnet dies ist auch
begrenzt sind dessen lippen vollziehen
dessen heißer körper weg lasst die
finger von ihm er hat die meisten hören
diesen witz nicht zum ersten mal
busreisen seien etwas für alte sagt das
einzige paar infos dass sie selber zwölf
enkel und urenkel haben und über 70 sind
darüber machen sie sich gerne lustig
das schöne sie leben
völlig unklar
wir sagen ich sage seinem 12
weniger
da sie gratis
dass hier mehr mädels zu
[Musik]
der zweitletzte abend in albi alle geben
sich möglichst festlich so wie jeden
abend
da spielt es keine rolle dass es draußen
noch hell ist und der barpianist längst
wegrationalisiert wurde
[Musik]
die zweite tour bus freundinnen lachen
sich gegenseitig die unzulänglichkeiten
weg das ist erfrischend oft der fall in
diesem bus spüren schmecken mit allen
sinnen wurden die gäste hier weit weg
von zu hause das ausland erleben dass
befriedigen
im rutschigen käsekeller
nicht verkürzt hat verloren sondern wer
liegen bleibt im rössli bus bleibt
garantiert niemand leben und wie viel
dieser sturz glimpflich aus
die rundumbetreuung ernst es gibt aber
grenzen der anteilnahme und land eine
probe ist gravierend
und dann gar nicht so einfach ich habe
schon gerne stellen die transpower
verbraucher bis 18
das also dass fröhlich hat gerne weg
wenn im bus die lebensgeschichten die
runden machen dafür verabschieden
unbeirrt 3000 kilometer werden sie am
schluss gefahren sein und der
pragmatische charme des
vier-sterne-hotels stört niemanden im
bus mangel hüten
irgendein apparat was sie brauchen über
nacht und waren mit dem taxifahrer
wieso vom busparkplatz nun wird es heute
nicht missen zentrum ihn aber natürlich
aufgeregt und dann ziehe ich behaupte
aber mappus parkplatz hat natürlich 100
mal vor hektik ist es erst wenn alle
luxe gestecke sind und auch die küche
verbracht und harmonie zum heil bringen
dem tisch doch kontakten lift immer
wieder neue tour und eben wie genau aber
die sind also da muss jemand
verabschiedet
ja so ist nötig werde man weiß ja dass
seine schwester stärken weiß nicht wer
monate aus
die stellen
mit
und ja die kohle
ja
tja
[Musik]